[Música]
hace unos años atrás visite la clínica
oftalmológica de la universidad de
montemorelos al hacerme varios estudios
los especialistas encontraron que tengo
una fosa muy grande en medio de mi
nervio óptico el nervio óptico tiene un
hoyo en el centro como una dona de pan
en el centro está el hoyo la periferia
es el pan
al decirme esto me preocupe pues en el
caso de tener glaucoma
el agujero va creciendo y el nervio
óptico se va haciendo cada vez más
delgado la mayoría de las personas
afectadas por glaucoma no presentan
síntomas en las primeras fases de la
enfermedad no obstante más adelante
aparecen defectos en el campo visual y
pérdida progresiva de la visión
básicamente la fase medio del nervio
óptico debe ocupar un tamaño total de 30
a 50 por ciento de la zona del nervio
óptico en mis ojos las fosas resultaron
ser del 70% en el pasado sin equipos
electrónicos adecuados yo hubiera sido
diagnosticado con glaucoma no obstante
mi caso es de macro disco en otras
palabras aunque tengo fosas muy grandes
hay suficiente pan en mi nervio óptico y
tengo buena visión
después de este estudio estuve pensando
acerca de glaucoma el glaucoma es la
segunda causa de ceguera en todo el
mundo y afecta aproximadamente a 7
millones de personas más aún más del 50%
de los casos de glaucoma permanecen sin
diagnosticar incluso en países
desarrollados
de hecho el glaucoma es la principal
causa de ceguera irreversible estos
hechos preocupantes me llevaron a
reflexionar acerca de tres desafíos en
el área médica en primer lugar el
diagnóstico de glaucoma y de otras
enfermedades tiende a ser su objetivo en
ausencia de herramientas adecuadas
afortunadamente en mi caso tuve un buen
diagnóstico no obstante si hay un
diagnóstico erróneo por ejemplo si una
persona es diagnosticada como paciente
sano teniendo glaucoma puede perder la
vista sin un tratamiento adecuado por
ejemplo si eeuu los diagnósticos
erróneos son desconcertantemente comunes
en ese país hay alrededor de 12 millones
de diagnósticos erróneos significativos
al año
un diagnóstico erróneo puede conducir a
malos tratamientos y a desperdicios
financieros
en segundo lugar con el fin de
diagnosticar enfermedades tales como el
glaucoma los oftalmólogos utilizan
equipos tecnológicos costosos que no se
encuentran en todas las clínicas por
este motivo necesitamos nuevas
herramientas que estén al alcance de la
mano y que puedan ser usadas en el
momento oportuno
por último hay varias enfermedades tales
como el glaucoma que se pueden prevenir
si se tratan a tiempo no obstante si los
pacientes no cuentan con el servicio
médico especializado estas enfermedades
seguirán su progreso silencioso y
destructivo por lo tanto es necesario
contar con aproximaciones novedosas para
la detección temprana de enfermedades
en esta presentación mostraré cómo se
puede aplicar la medicina 4.0 para
enfrentar estos grandes desafíos y así
facilitar la labor de los médicos y
mejorar la calidad del servicio de los
pacientes
la medicina 4.0 es la medicina en la
cuarta revolución industrial en la cual
estamos viviendo hay tres ingredientes
que han dado lugar al nuevo éxito de la
aplicación de la inteligencia artificial
a la medicina
el primer ingrediente es la
disponibilidad y el acceso a grandes
volúmenes de datos digitales
relacionados con el cuidado de la salud
vivimos en la era de los datos masivos
la big data
el segundo ingrediente es el desarrollo
de unidades de procesamiento gráfico gpu
que permiten el procesamiento en
paralelo de los datos masivos
el último ingrediente es el desarrollo
de nuevas aproximaciones de inteligencia
artificial la inteligencia artificial es
la teoría y el desarrollo de sistemas
computacionales que son capaces de
llevar a cabo tareas que normalmente
requieren inteligencia humana tales como
la percepción visual
por otro lado el aprendizaje automático
un subconjunto de la inteligencia
artificial es el estudio de algoritmos
que mejoran automáticamente a través de
la experiencia con datos de
entrenamiento en otras palabras mediante
el aprendizaje automático es posible
crear modelos con el conocimiento de uno
o muchos expertos en un tema determinado
luego estos modelos se pueden utilizar
en sistemas inteligentes que sirven por
ejemplo para detectar diferentes
enfermedades
por otro lado el aprendizaje de
representaciones o de características
permite que un sistema descubra de forma
automática las representaciones por
ejemplo colores o también formas
necesarias para la detección o
clasificación de características a
partir de datos sin procesar
finalmente el aprendizaje profundo que
en la actualidad es el área de más alta
ebullición en el campo de la
inteligencia artificial introduce
representaciones que se expresan en
términos de otras representaciones más
simples el ejemplo por excelencia de un
modelo de aprendizaje profundo son las
redes neuronales artificiales profundas
con múltiples capas inspiradas en el
procesamiento de información que tenemos
en nuestro cerebro
en 2012 una aproximación llamada a
lexnet basada en aprendizaje profundo
redujo la tasa de error en
aproximadamente un 10 por ciento en 2015
res net superó la exactitud de los
humanos en el reconocimiento de imágenes
con una tasa de error de o por debajo
del 5% desde entonces la tasa de error
en el reconocimiento de imágenes ha
caído por debajo del 3% estos hechos
indican el potencial del aprendizaje
profundo en nuestra vida incluyendo por
supuesto la salud
todas las interacciones de la
computadora consisten en una entrada una
función y una salida en la programación
de computadoras tradicionales escribimos
funciones mediante reglas codificadas
manualmente por el contrario del
aprendizaje automático se basa en el
reconocimiento de patrones sin requerir
una programación explícita en otras
palabras los modelos de aprendizaje
automático aprenden esta función de
ejemplos de entrada y correspondientes
salidas deseadas luego estos modelos
pueden producir predicciones confiables
irrepetibles como salida
en el caso de clasificar imágenes
mediante aprendizaje automático
la solución toma una fotografía por
ejemplo de fondo de ojo y genera las
probabilidades para un conjunto
predefinido de clases en este caso
glaucoma y no glaucoma un modelo de
clasificación realiza las inferencias al
aprender las características esenciales
de imágenes de fondo de ojo con glaucoma
y sin glaucoma este modelo fue creado
previamente con imágenes clasificadas
por un especialista por un oftalmólogo
al usar una red neuronal profunda como
mecanismo de aprendizaje automático hay
una primera capa en esta imagen con
neuronas en color verde que asimilan los
datos de entrada las primeras capas
identifican los valores de los píxeles
por ejemplo píxeles claros u oscuros y
los bordes dentro de la imagen las
siguientes capas identifican
combinaciones de características y
características dentro de la imagen qué
diferencia en una imagen de una persona
con glaucoma de una persona sana la
última capa con dos neuronas en color
amarillo combina las características
identificadas para indicar la
clasificación una neurona indica la
presencia de glaucoma y otra la ausencia
de la enfermedad
en los últimos años he estado trabajando
en diversas investigaciones
investigaciones multidisciplinarias de
medicina 4.0 con colegas médicos aquí en
la universidad de montemorelos en una
primera investigación construimos una
solución basada en una red neuronal
profunda para la predicción automática
de glaucoma específicamente tomamos 25
fotografías de fondo de ojo de personas
con un diagnóstico confirmado de
glaucoma y 19 fotografías de pacientes
que no presentaban síntomas de esta
enfermedad con estas fotografías re
entrenamos una red neuronal artificial
con topología inception versión 3
estas dos tablas muestran los resultados
obtenidos al ingresar seis imágenes de
fondo de ojo cada fila muestra el
porcentaje de exactitud de la
clasificación que en promedio fue de 99
por ciento actualmente hemos estado
trabajando en una nueva solución para
detectar glaucoma en pacientes latinos
utilizando imágenes del mapa de grosor
de la capa de fibras nerviosas de la
retina
hablemos acerca de otra investigación en
esta segunda investigación trabajamos en
la aproximación computacional para
detectar melanoma maligno una enfermedad
que ha aumentado de manera significativa
en las últimas cuatro décadas este es el
tipo más peligroso de cáncer de piel su
diagnóstico precoz facilita un
tratamiento eficaz sin embargo si el
diagnóstico se retrasa el cáncer puede
hacer metástasis en otros órganos
el melanoma es el cáncer más frecuente
en adultos jóvenes de 25 a 29 años y el
segundo cáncer más frecuente de aquellos
entre 15 y 29 años
en américa latina' parece que estamos
librando una batalla perdida en la
disminución de la mortalidad asociada
con el melanoma de hecho para muchos
pacientes es difícil ser evaluados por
un dermatólogo debido a la baja
proporción de especialistas en la
población y los bajos ingresos per
cápita con el fin de enfrentar esta
enfermedad creamos un software que
distingue de manera automática y
objetiva entre una lesión de melanoma y
un nuevo ve digno de una manera simple y
no invasiva nuestro enfoque se basa en
una red neuronal artificial el modelo de
clasificación fue entrenado con 50
imágenes de melanoma maligno previamente
diagnosticadas y 50 imágenes de lunares
sospechosos no malignos obteniendo una
sensibilidad de alrededor del 76 por
ciento y una especificidad de alrededor
del 87%
en una tercera investigación nos
enfocamos en el problema de la detección
de una vía aérea difícil mediante
aprendizaje profundo
siempre que un paciente necesita
ingresar al quirófano en caso de que la
cirugía requiera anestesia general el
paciente debe ser intubado y el
anestesiólogo debe realizar un control
previo al paciente para evaluar su vía
aérea este proceso debe realizarse para
anticipar cualquier problema como una
vía aérea difícil al momento de ser
anestesiado una vía aérea difícil se
define como la necesidad de tres o más
intentos para incubar la tráquea o más
de 10 minutos para lograrlo
aproximadamente a esta situación ocurre
en 1.5 a 8 por ciento de los
procedimientos en los que se utiliza
anestesia general la incidencia de la
situación de paciente no intocable está
presente en uno de cada cincuenta mil
pacientes asimismo el fallo de la
intubación orotraqueal se produce en 1
de cada 2.000 casos programados
aumentando a 1 de cada 200 casos en
urgencias
la detección inadecuada de una vía aérea
difícil puede provocar complicaciones
graves e incluso la muerte
de hecho la incapacidad para manejar con
éxito una vía aérea difícil es
responsable el 25 al 30 por ciento de
las muertes atribuibles a la anestesia
es por esto que una vía aérea difícil es
uno de los grandes desafíos de los
anestesiólogos en este trabajo de
investigación
creamos una aplicación móvil que utiliza
una red neuronal convolución 'la para
detectar una diaria difícil este modelo
clasifica dos clases de la puntuación
malam para ti a saber malam para ti 1 y
2 con bajo riesgo de viaria difícil y
mala para ti 3 y 4 con mayor riesgo de
diaria difícil la exactitud promedio el
modelo predictivo fue alrededor del 88%
para clasificar imágenes se utilizaron
un total de 240 imágenes para entrenar
el modelo los resultados de sensibilidad
y especificidad fueron del 90 por ciento
en promedio
los esfuerzos y los talentos combinados
de los humanos
junto con la inteligencia artificial
trabajando en manera sinérgica pueden
producir un triunfo médico en el
contexto de la medicina 4.0 no obstante
esta no es una tarea fácil tal como lo
menciona eric topol en su libro de
medicina aunque la mayoría de los
sectores del mundo ya están encarrilados
en la cuarta revolución industrial la
medicina todavía está estancada en la
fase inicial de la tercera revolución
que vio el primer uso generalizado de
las computadoras y la electrónica con el
fin de alcanzar la medicina 4.0 es
importante desarrollar proyectos
multidisciplinarios que saquen lo mejor
de los médicos y de los ingenieros para
explotar el potencial de la inteligencia
artificial y de los datos en la medicina
en este sentido el rol de las
universidades es vital en la creación de
proyectos de investigación en medicina
4.0 que sirvan para solucionar problemas
de salud tanto locales como mundiales al
alcanzar la medicina 4.0 habremos
encontrado un remedio para apoyar el
diagnóstico médico y evitar
procedimientos innecesarios
asimismo lograremos democratizar la
medicina con sistemas inteligentes que
se pueden ejecutar aún en nuestros
dispositivos electrónicos personales
finalmente mejoraremos la calidad de
vida de los pacientes con diagnósticos
más rápidos que sirvan para tratar la
enfermedad a tiempo
[Música]